it's unfair for her to get mad at dad
for that when she gave up she's through
the towel in she said I'm done
she treated first sister wife star
mikelty padrone slams Mary for cheating
on her father Cody I'm Not Angry Anymore
I'm not hurt anymore
so you know that's real progress the 26
year old daughter of Cody and Christine
spoke out about it during a crowdcast
live with her husband Tony the topic
marries 2015 catfishing Scandal I
thought I was talking to a man online
it wasn't a man
it was a woman
pretending to be a man when you cheat on
somebody you're giving up first if
you're gonna cheat on your spouse you
are giving up on the relationship first
Sometimes things aren't better but
sometimes but then they always do get
better that's the thing that I find you
know you just work through it and then
you get to a point that's good and while
mckelty did acknowledge Mary didn't have
a physical relationship with anyone she
thinks it was an emotional affair there
is a difference between an emotional
affair and a physical Affair but Mariah
heard them on the phone having
intimate conversations on over the phone
Mariah heard them have intimate
conversation over the phone and if
you're sexting or verbal sexting or
whatever that's that's cheating that's
still cheating if it would not have been
a girl getting to be a guy
who knows what could happen mckelty also
explains why Mary shouldn't be upset
with her dad and it's unfair for her to
get mad at dad for that when she gave up
she's through the travel in she said I'm
done
she treated first Mary and I are in an
amiable relationship but we've been like
literally separated for I would say four
or five years so we're we're amiable
we've had a real struggle yeah since
Mary's catfishing Scandal her
relationship with Cody was strained Cody
and I are in this situation
we're not legally married
I want to work on the relationship but
Cody has basically said that he doesn't
does that mean we're just not married
anymore
that's not how I consider it I don't
really consider myself married to Mary
I just if she wanted to if she wanted to
move on and marry another she wouldn't
get an argument with me I don't believe
that we can ever be functional
and I don't believe that I will ever be
emotionally safe with her it's a
estranged marriage it's it's a marriage
that needs to work out some stuff but
fast forward to 2023 and things didn't
work out Cody and Mary officially
announced they are permanently
terminating their marriage after more
than a decade of trying to fix things he
says no I don't consider myself married
to Mary
like he just made the decision I've
never heard him say that to me yeah but
Cody and Mary also noted they're
committed to kindness and respect toward
one another moving forward
[Music]